a new book highlights the potentially
harmful effects of thousands of
chemicals in our food environment and
household and personal care products
evidence suggest these chemicals like
pesticides and phthalates may be linked
to serious diseases like obesity
diabetes brain disorders and fertility
problems it's detailed in dr. Leonardo
true Sunday's new book thicker fatter
poor the urgent threat of hormone
disrupting chemicals to our health and
future and what we can do about it
in a statement to CBS this morning the
American Chemistry Council said quote to
stay below ranges of exposure determined
to be saved consumers should read
product labels closely and follow
directions carefully the trade group for
personal care products says because Val
eighths are widely widely used in many
consumer products not just kept
cosmetics and personal care products
their safety has been extensively
researched and reviewed we did not hear
back from the FDA because of the partial
government shutdown dr. Chris Sunday is
an associate professor of pediatrics
environmental medicine and population
health at NYU Langone health good
morning welcome to the table good
morning you start the book off with an
ominous comparison of a New York City
playground in 1962 and that of one today
where the children are fatter and not as
healthy and you kill you attribute a lot
of that to these hormone disrupting
chemicals what are they
so hormones are molecules that our body
uses to signal and communicate and
hormone disruptors are chemicals that
scramble those signals and contribute to
disease we know now of over a thousand
chemicals that are hormone disruptors
the evidence is particularly strong for
four categories of chemicals pesticides
which are used in agriculture and
phthalates which are used in personal
care products and food packaging
bisphenol x' which are Lou use and
aluminum can linings and thermal paper
receipts and brominated flame retardants
which are used in furniture electronics
and even mattresses so they're basically
in almost all parts of our lives yes and
use you put you see a very strong link
here to obesity and 40% of Americans are
obese according to the surveys that's
where the science has gone with leaps
and bounds
nothing I'm describing here suggests
that
vocals are the only factor driving the
obesity epidemic diet and physical
inactivity are clearly the leading
factors to that evidence so how do they
compare these chemicals contribute them
so they scramble hormone signals and
allow us to and shift our diet and how
its transformed in our body into fat as
opposed into muscle or other categories
and so the reality here is that they're
safe and simple steps we can take to
limit those exposures which may be
easier to accomplish as opposed to
changing diet and physical activity
which can be more fundamentally
difficult and our children are
particularly vulnerable yes
pound for pound they're breathing more
air eating more food and drinking more
water so their have greater exposure and
they're developing organ systems are
uniquely vulnerable so what steps can we
take to limit our exposure to these
hormone disruptors the great news is
that there's many safe and simple steps
families can take avoiding a contact
with aluminum can linings by avoiding
canned food altogether reducing
bisphenol exposures one way simply
looking at the plastic bottle if you're
using that and checking the number the
numbers 3 6 & 7 are not safe for you
sick where do you find that number it's
on the bottom of the plastic so any cuts
of container there's like a triangle
yeah number in the bottom of it's very
good you know problem 3 or 4 phthalates
six are four bits up for styrene a known
carcinogen and seven are for bisphenol
which are a synthetic estrogen that can
also disrupt metabolism you start the
book when talking about children nor I
mentioned children as well the FDA
banned BPA in baby bottles and sippy
cups back in 2012 last year it said that
BPA is safe for consumers what is your
reaction to that is BPA safe or
consumers
they're always shades of grey as the
science tries to catch up but even the
FDA's own science suggests effects at
lower levels of exposure that are common
in humans word up plays much like we
were with LED and tobacco smoke 20 or 30
years ago we have to ask ourselves
fundamentally what how we're going to
gamble with our health whether we want
to take that gamble and in in that
context that's why I'm here talking
about this book because we need to
empower consumers to make up their own
minds and take the safe and simple stuff
they need let me ask you about
regulation because when it comes to
Europe their governments regulate
chemical use much more than than our
government does are you seeing a
difference in how consumers are reacting
to those chemicals or the regulation the
reality is the policy predicts exposure
exposure predicts disease and disease
ultimately costs our economy we found
that these exposures cost the United
States three hundred forty billion
dollars a year that's two point three
percent of our gross domestic product so
interesting thank you my pleasure